alors anthony est avec nous merci d'être
avec nous Anthony chauffeur VTC et
Brahim syndicalise BTC merci d'être là
Brahim également c'est vrai que on a vu
cette agression elle a énormément ton
esprit la première fois que ça vous
arrivait première fois en 5 ans ça fait
5 ans que vous êtes ici
tout se passe bien jusqu'à jeudi dernier
comment ça s'est passé vous ont appelé
ou vous ont appelé ils vous ont commandé
vous êtes arrivés une course lambda
comme tous les jours je commence ma
journée
deuxième course de la journée et puis
[Musique]
puis elle a voulu me comment dire
m'arnaquer me faire une filouterie par
rapport à l'argent que je lui donne 50
euros pour qu'elle aille chercher un
billet de 100 départs
j'arrive elle me dit qu'elle a qu'un
billet de 100 c'est une course à peu
près 50 euros d'accord que je lui donne
50 € et qu'ensuite elle me ramène la
monnaie j'ai refusé d'accord oui donc
c'est donnez-moi 50 euros je vous ramène
ça tout de suite donc je l'ai d'accord
mais bon donc en fait ouais d'accord
donc après il monte quand même dans la
voiture elle était avec eux je vais
chercher l'argent je reviens elle était
toute seule à la base donc elle revient
avec le monsieur et au final ils veulent
pas payer je demande de payer comme
c'est une course en espèces et parce que
là on vous voit rouler oui bah c'est au
moment où je ralentis il voulait pas
payer donc j'ai dit on va on va en
rester là je ralentis pour les déposer
et moi je passe à autre chose et c'est
au moment de ralentir oui c'est passé
parce que en fait donc vous allez au
départ vous allez la chercher toute
seule et vous lui donnez moi 50 euros je
vous donne 100 c'est ça maintenant elle
remonte et elle redescend avec vous
partez en course
non non après on part en course je leur
demande de payer la course et il refuse
ils disent qu'il me dit qu'elle a pas
d'argent on donc je décide d'arrêter la
course là j'ai des postes sur un parking
à gauche le parking où on voit que je
roule d'accord et puis au moment de
ralentir pour qu'il descende
il m'agresse quoi ok il avait quoi là
normalement sur le fait j'ai rien vu
c'est en regardant les vidéos que
j'aperçois qu'il y a quelque chose dans
la main et je peux pas dire ce que c'est
peut-être un briquet ou un couteau ou
une seringue un esprit il vous tape ici
un moment c'est ça c'est ça vise le coup
et le visage ouais c'est ça donc là vous
vous là vous vous dites qu'est-ce que
c'est que ce traquenard ah oui j'ai eu
peur pour ma vie donc mon premier
réflexe est de j'ai vu des gens dans la
rue d'ouvrir le carreau et hurler et
vous avez hurlé c'est la meilleure chose
à faire je pense que ça m'a je pense que
ça m'a bien
vous pensez qu'il c'est vrai que ça le
cri voilà tu penses les tétanismes les
deux on les voit ils veulent ils veulent
descendre du véhicule le véhicule roule
vous roulez vous dites on va tous vous
accélérez à fond c'est ça c'est ça c'est
quoi votre idée vous êtes dit vous avez
réagi comme ça vous êtes dit c'est je
pense qu'il y a que ça à faire je me
suis dit il faut que je les effraie pour
qu'ils partent et que
je me débarrasse de quoi et je pense que
ça a marché on voit la fin ils sont
effrayés bien sûr ils ouvrent la porte
et ils sont on voit la dame aussi qui
essaie de vous agresser
il regarde tout au milieu il y avait
quoi il y avait de l'argent il y avait
mon téléphone sur au milieu d'accord les
clés de la voiture d'accord et l'argent
non l'argent il s'est en dessous de
l'accoudoir donc je sais pas ce qu'elle
veut attraper peut-être éteindre la
voiture peut-être prendre mon télé mon
téléphone j'ai pas je sais pas d'accord
derrière vous avez porté plainte vous
avez tout de suite j'ai porté plainte et
les individus ont été retrouvés c'est en
cours parce que on voit leur visage
extrêmement bien sur les réseaux sociaux
normalement ça devrait pas ça devrait
pas tarder j'espère
j'ai un peu vous avez été aujourd'hui
quand vous refaites vous avez repris les
courses non non j'ai pas je compte pas
reprendre tout de suite pour l'instant
je me sens pas prêt de pour l'instant
vous êtes
j'essaie de de passer à autre chose et
je me sens pas pris dans l'immédiat
reprendre le boulot vous avez été très
choqué parce qu'il s'est passé
franchement je suis traumatisé
[Musique]
vous dites je pourrais plus conduire
comme avant je fais toujours avoir un
œil
devoir reprendre le boulot un jour mais
ce sera plus comme avant j'aurais une
crainte et surtout quand quelqu'un
montre derrière moi c'est ça toujours
cette crainte
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que c'est courant
chez les VTC aujourd'hui Brahim vous
êtes syndicative VTC ce qui a souvent il
y a beaucoup de cas comme ça bah écoutez
on a appris cet après-midi déjà que le
mouvement uber Server reprend on a des
agressions sexuelles qui ont été
déclarées cet après-midi sur les
plateformes hitch et Hubert donc
agression client et chauffeur maintenant
finalement il y a de la sécurité on a
banalisé ça pendant des années moi
j'avais averti du coup j'avais proposé
des solutions et là c'est devenu
affluent donc moi je pense que là si on
fait pas quelque chose et comprend pas
des mesures tout de suite j'ai peur
qu'on arrive à un drame quoi
ce qui arrive à Anthony ça c'est
choquant c'est choquant alors
apparemment ils auraient été retrouvés
les deux personnes
c'est ce qu'on dit c'est ça qu'ils
auraient été retrouvés on va voir mais
ce couple est connu dans apparemment des
services de police apparemment c'est pas
la première fois qu'ils font ça je
confirme c'est ça vous étiez au courant
oui en fait nous on a su il y a des
personnes qui se sont déclarées aussi
donc c'était le même couple avec des
fois différentes personnes et la
plateforme Bolt n'a jamais pris
l'initiative de les déconnecter donc du
coup là il y a des enquêtes en cours je
peux pas trop parler mais voilà on verra
ce qui va se passer la première fois
qu'ils font ça non d'accord il y a eu
énormément d'agressions de de VTC ou pas
il y a eu beaucoup je vais vous raconter
une anecdote et on a une console une
fois même chose même procédé on l'a
amené dans un coin paumé elle a été
braquée à l'armure on lui a pris son
téléphone on l'a frappé violemment elle
était traumatisée à ce jour un exercice
plus
et c'est une femme je l'ai accompagné on
a réussi à obtenir une compensation
financière de la plateforme c'est
dérisoire quoi par rapport au préjudice
ça a été quoi la compensation je vais
être honnête avec vous c'était 6000
euros pour moi et encore 6000 euros
parce que c'est même pas prévu dans les
conditions d'utilisation de la
plateforme c'est vraiment j'ai essayé
d'aller accompagner demander au moins
quelque chose mais c'est très difficile
de les attaquer sur la responsabilité
même les avocats refusent ils se disent
que voilà il faut vraiment des éléments
parce que c'est une plateforme
d'intermédiation voilà Anthony
aujourd'hui vous nous avez dit que vous
alliez mettre un petit peu de temps à
à reprendre le travail vous habitez à
Lille
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que franchement
on se met on se met à sa place on se dit
c'est compliqué de reprendre et moi
quand je vois j'ai vu les deux là leur
comportement vers Anthony même les je
vous jure je supporte plus ce genre de
vidéo oui mais les images sont
extrêmement choquantes et quand on voit
ça on se dit que il y a peut-être tout
le système des VTC à revoir parce qu'il
y a de plus en plus d'agression de
chauffeurs de plus en plus d'agressions
de passagers je crois qu'il y a de moins
en moins de chauffeurs parce que les
conditions de travail se dégradent
malheureusement les gens ne veulent rien
payer ni les chauffeurs ni les courses
donc ça crée des tensions est-ce que
c'est pas tout le modèle des VTC qu'il
faut revoir selon vous moi je vais vous
répondre ça fait des années que
justement je défonce secteur on a assez
faire ma voix clairement ou je vais
répondre à votre question n'a pas eu le
temps une fois quand j'étais venu
on paye une TVA sur les 25% de la
commission Aubert est-ce que c'est
normal qu'aujourd'hui on doit payer à la
place du Berre est-ce que c'est normal
qu'aujourd'hui on nous impose une
tarification on nous dit c'est comme ça
vous voulez vous voulez pas on vous
déconnecte du jour au lendemain on nous
dit que ça crée de l'emploi non ça crée
du chômage parce que je peux vous dire
qu'il y a des personnes qui ont exercé
deux trois mois et qui sont déconnectés
à tort et le pire dans cette histoire là
c'est qu'il y a rien qui va on est dans
une société de où nous surveille parce
que dans la plateforme ce qu'on a
découvert c'est effrayant c'est que nous
finalement notre insu on les écoute à
notre insulte nos données personnelles
par ailleurs il y a tout à revoir on
veut sécuriser ça va pas aujourd'hui il
y a une directive européenne qui est
portée pour justement améliorer les
conditions de travail il y a des
lobbyings de malades et pour terminer
j'étais tout à l'heure au Parlement
européen je reviens donc du Parlement je
retrouve valobistes qui disent mais ils
sont il y a la flexibilité ils peuvent
travailler à tout moment alors je pose
la question à Tony aujourd'hui Anthony
qui a subi cet accident là il vit de
quoi pas de protection bien sûr pas les
moyens justement
de financer quoi que ce soit et il se
retrouve excusez-moi au chômage
technique et il pourra voir
en fait il y a des des histoires un peu
farfelues des mythes mais en réalité si
on revient sur l'article d'un coup la
Cour des comptes beaucoup de chauffeurs
ne déclare pas parce qu'ils savent même
pas comment fonctionne la déclaration
URSSAF vous voyez il y en a qui voilà un
chauffeur franchement honnêtement ça
dépend il y a des périodes il y a des
périodes où en moyenne en moyenne en
moyenne ça peut être par exemple à Paris
on est sur 2000 € de chiffre d'affaires
pour 80 € de 80 heures de connexion donc
ça fait en moyenne avec toutes les
charges et tout à peu près 1003400 donc
voilà parce que ils sont en propriétaire
de leur véhicule lui ce qui a pas mal de
charges le carburant dans le carburant
est-ce qu'on s'en sort quand on est
chauffeurs VTC ou pas on s'en sort mais
on fait plus d'heures pour pour moins
moins de chiffre d'affaires donc ça
c'est ça donc vous vous travaillez
combien d'heures par jour
ça peut aller de
6 7 jusqu'à 13 14 15 ça m'est déjà
arrivé 14 15 est-ce qu'on connaît le
profil des agresseurs ou pas du tout
est-ce que vous pouvez dire à Brahim de
vous mettez pas parce que je vois je
vous dis énormément de gens sur les
réseaux sociaux j'ai vu qui ont filmé
voilà qui filment la graisseuse voilà
parce qu'ils ont retrouvé ils l'ont
repéré elle a été convoqué apparemment
par au commissariat voilà et elle se
cache depuis sa convocation enfin elle
veut pas elle veut pas voir elle veut
voir personne est-ce que vous avez des
est-ce que vous connaissez le profil
est-ce que les gens qui sont des gens de
voilà
je préfère pas répondre alors je peux te
donner deux éléments il y a une personne
qui a été identifiée l'autre pour
l'instant pour toujours la jeune femme a
été jeune femme elle a été identifiée
sur les réseaux sociaux donc si on
identité était partagée par pas mal de
personnes mais la deuxième personne pour
l'instant toujours
c'est la personne qui
le garçon avec avec on sait pas ce qu'il
avait parce qu'il vous
c'est pas ce que c'était on sait pas ce
qu'il a cherché oui est-ce que dans ces
cas-là quand vous êtes victime d'une
agression la plateforme pour laquelle
vous travaillez vous ennemises bonne
question c'est la première fois que ça
m'arrive j'attends toujours un retour de
leur part à sujet là je peux répondre
non non parce que dans les conditions
d'utilisation générale c'est une
plateforme d'intermédiation c'est pas
une plateforme qui emploie des salariés
des indépendants donc c'est non
catégorique voilà au niveau de la la
dashcam alors comment ça se passe parce
que vous vous aviez donc cette caméra
c'est pour ça qu'on a pu voir cette
vidéo tournée sur les réseaux vous
l'achetez ça coûte combien
il y a plusieurs modèles la mienne coûte
un petit 200 euros et à la base je
l'achète pour me mettre en sécurité
d'accord ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui et
aussi pour les accidents de la route
pour me protéger c'est quelqu'un recule
me rentre dedans dans les deux cas côté
client et côté accident routier et je
regrette pas de l'avoir d'avoir investi
et sans les vidéos je pense pas que je
serai là aujourd'hui
vous pensez
que ça aurait pu aller plus loin ah oui
je m'estime heureux je pense que je m'en
sors bien et ça aurait pu être plus
dramatique que ça
vous voilà aujourd'hui le profil on sait
que c'est des récidivistes aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il n'y a pas est-ce qu'on va
pas penser peut-être à mettre des vitres
maintenant pendant le covid j'avais mis
une vitre en plexiglas pour pour le
covid justement mais je pense quand je
vais reprendre le travail mettre une la
remettre je l'ai encore chez moi je vais
la remettre puisque vous êtes trop
traumatisé on comprend il faut prendre
un petit peu de temps et peut-être là
pour l'instant la remettre pas ça vous
allez être tranquille comme ça mais
c'est vrai que voilà n'importe quoi ça
tenir des camions blindés maintenant les
taxis on est en train de marcher sur la
tête pour des abrutis qui font des trucs
comme ça maintenant faut se barricader
de partout ça met deux abrutis
on a les noms on va avoir les identités
parce qu'il a inversé la peur c'est à
dire qu'il leur fait peur à eux en
accélérant lundi on va se tuer mais si
en perdant le contrôle de sa voiture il
tape une maman avec une poussette
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des deux là ça
aurait pu être très grave après comme ça
Christopher humeur qui a
commis une agression sexuelle sur une
jeune fille voilà donc là aujourd'hui si
tout le monde doit se protéger tout le
monde c'est vrai que c'est c'est non
mais c'est formidable parce que à la
fois pour eux et à la fois pour le
passager parce qu'il y avait également
se chauffeur d'une plateforme quelconque
qui a séquestré une jeune fille c'était
pas la première fois mais là aussi la
caméra peut aider justement à trouver
oui j'ai une question pour Anthony parce
que si vous nous rejoignez il est 20h31
sachez qu'Antony et ce chauffeur VTC qui
a été agressé voilà par de personnes qui
voulaient faire une voulais qu'il fasse
une course et vraiment vous avez la
bonne réaction client comme ça c'est
vrai parce que je pense que vraiment
style j'ai vu ils étaient tétanisés la
peur a changé
c'était pas le train ils ont voulu faire
les bonhommes il a crié il accélère et
on va tous se tuer arrête la voiture ils
sont partis comme des valeurs c'est des
baltringues ces gens-là ils mettent la
vie en danger d'autres personnes parce
que récidive
peut-être sa vie en danger
un moment donné
votre réflexe il est incroyable Anthony
c'est-à-dire que vous vous sauvez la vie
vous réagissez comme ça et j'ai
l'impression à vous entendre que vous
n'étiez pas préparé c'est à dire que
l'entreprise jamais vous a dit en cas
d'agression faites ça il y a pas de
consigne pas de conseils rien du tout
vous êtes laissé comme ça seul agresser
nous prévient pas attention il y a des
risques tout ça si on n'est pas au
courant et je pense que j'ai une bonne
réaction j'ai c'était instinctif j'ai
pas réfléchi vous avez quel âge Anthony
27 ans 27 ans c'est la première fois que
vous faites agresser
donc là c'est vrai que c'est un
traumatisme bon bien sûr
mais c'est vrai que je vois Anthony
vraiment on voit on le voit choqué oui
Delphine en fait on se rend compte
qu'aujourd'hui en France tous les
métiers où on est en contact avec des
gens que ce soit chauffeur VTC que ce
soit chauffeur de bus il faudrait avoir
des formations de de self-défense c'est
vraiment très triste je sais qu'il y a
aussi des chauffeurs qui ne mettent pas
la ceinture donc ils se mettent en
danger tout ça pour en cas d'agression
pouvoir sortir plus vite du véhicule
aujourd'hui Anthony vous pour de pouvoir
vivre votre métier pleinement que ce que
vous est-ce que tu aimerais que qui
change en fait surtout le problème
d'insécurité la rémunération et je pense
que ce serait déjà deux bonnes choses
mais la sécurité comment est-ce qu'on
peut la changer si c'est pas les
politiques
il y a plus confiance
on parle de la dashcam attention il y a
il peut avoir des dérives puisque
aujourd'hui c'est déjà installé donc
dans les bus de la RATP il faut effacer
la loi les tristique sur les rgpd c'est
toutes les 48 heures donc aujourd'hui
nous on veut vraiment que les vidéos
appartiennent au chauffeur le but c'est
pas de télétransmettre les données et
qu'on fait du flicage et qu'on est dans
une société de surveillance ça c'est pas
le but mais je pense qu'il faut mettre
des dispositifs parce que c'est dashcam
je rappelle une histoire très courte
vous rappelez de la vidéo avec donc
Travis scalachnique qui a un moment
monte dans le véhicule et qui donc
interpelle le chauffeur limite la
graisse verbalement et cette vidéo elle
a été virale le chauffeur justement a
tourné cette scène où bah un PDG qui
respecte pas les chauffeurs et du coup
ça a permis de montrer une image d'une
société donc voilà c'est hyper important
mais pour ma part moi je suis favorable
on a une réunion a terminé ministérielle
voilà et on verra ce qu'on va et le
dernier point je peux inviterai jour
Clément Beaune actuellement je serai
ravi's qui est très sympa en plus qui je
monte assez bien qui sera peut-être ravi
d'être en face de vous et de pouvoir
débattre avec vous en tout cas merci
beaucoup et si vous voulez en savoir un
peu plus donc à bout de course qui sort
sur France 2 donc format 26 octobre à
23h sur infrarouge allez regarder contre
l'histoire des chauffeurs contre la
plateforme exactement merci à vous en
tout cas merci à vous deux